en 2020 el mundo entero fue sacudido por
una crisis sanitaria que aún no se ha
acabado pero algunas de las medidas
adoptadas para abordar la han tenido un
efecto devastador en la vida de millones
de personas en un análisis sobre la
situación en 149 países amnistía
internacional alerta que numerosos
gobiernos están instrumentalizando la
crisis sanitaria del cobi 19 para
avanzar en sus propias agendas wisconsin
descubrimos que en todo el mundo el
hobbit 19 ha amplificado las
desigualdades existentes sin
discriminación exacerbando la
discriminación y la desigualdad y las
personas más pobres en particular son
las más afectadas por el cob ido por la
respuesta a este virus
la mayoría de los que murieron ya
estaban entre los grupos vulnerables
white way y wing and demons fellner bull
caps
la ong ha firme su reporte que los
gobiernos de medio oriente han usado las
medidas preventivas para hacer frente al
hobbit 19 como un pretexto para cometer
más abusos de los derechos humanos
en áfrica la brutalidad de la policía de
nigeria ha provocado que las fuerzas de
seguridad maten a personas por
manifestar en las calles en europa
destacan las acciones del primer
ministro de hungría viktor orbán que
reformó el código penal para introducir
penas de hasta cinco años de cárcel por
divulgar información falsa sobre el
coronavirus en países como méxico
venezuela colombia y el salvador los
ataques a periodistas y defensores de
derechos humanos aumentaron dando lugar
a una furia social que fue contenida con
la excusa de la cuarentena por el coi 19
también con el pretexto de la pandemia
sostiene el informe
eeuu detuvo y deportó a medio millón de
migrantes y solicitantes de asilo además
las mujeres son las grandes afectadas en
esta crisis con un considerable aumento
de la violencia de género y violencia
intrafamiliar